[Music]
on this episode of explorer
i'm in the atacama desert which
stretches about 600 miles
along the coast of chile what really
makes the atacama desert
so unique is that they have clear dark
skies
untouched by light pollution one of the
reasons they built
the world's most advanced optical
telescope here
i'm gonna stare trillions of miles off
into space
this would have been one of the biggest
discoveries in recent years it's if not
the biggest
also correspondent albert lim looks into
a bold new plan to get an astronaut
safely to mars how do we put a human
into a state of hibernation
this unlikely creature may hold the key
it's built into the genome
and we possess those genes too
plus mariana vanzela looks into a
growing movement in america
people who believe the earth is flat we
have
photos from space that prove that the
earth is round
and nobody here believes any of that
anymore
and cara santa maria unveils the shadowy
and lucrative world
of meteorite trading the rarest mars
rock on earth
sells for 10 000 us per gram it's
science versus
profit in the race to find rocks from
outer space
this really has the potential to be the
most expensive meteorite we've ever sold
wow
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to explore i'm phil cogan our
species have always been
stargazers looking up an ore and
wondering
what's out there in this episode we
follow that ancient curiosity
to its modern frontier our first story
is about scientists
who believe they've found the key to
enabling humans to becoming
interplanetary travelers here's albert
lin
in houston
[Music]
if you watch any science fiction you
know that deep space travel is going to
involve some kind of glass and steel
hibernation chamber
[Music]
but how do we put a human into a state
of hibernation
well that brings us here to this forest
and the fat-tailed dwarf lemur
an unlikely linchpin in our quest to
become an interplanetary species
[Music]
the colonization of mars it seems
inevitable
but the first challenge we need to
overcome is simply getting humans to
survive
the nine-month trip there to find out
how
big that hurdle really is i'm talking to
the man who spent the most
time in space astronaut scott kelly
does it even come close to what it feels
like to get shot up in this map no i'm
not it's not closed at all
[Laughter]
it certainly feels like it's me
i mean you really are the example of how
we might survive a journey towards mars
how many days have you spent in space so
i spent 520 days in
space on four space flights
kelly spent nearly a year on the
international space station
and underwent unprecedented medical
tests to determine the impact of
prolonged space travel on the human body
and the bottom line is is not good
as you spend more and more time in space
you know
physiologically bad things happen
our physiology recognizes that hey
i don't need these bones to support
everything else anymore
we get rid of that bone mass through
urination
so you pee out your bones basically yeah
you pee out a lot of calcium one percent
a month so you know after
100 months you would have no bones if
you didn't do
anything about it also radiation
is a big concern what would be the
equivalent in terms of
like for example a chest x-ray you know
to one day in space
at the space station 10 to 20 chest
x-rays every day
every single day for a year it damages
your cells but kelly says we
fail to overcome these obstacles at our
peril
in the long scheme of things we will go
beyond right
our world will cease to exist the
expiration date for humans on earth
is somewhere on the horizon and many say
the steady rising population will drain
the already dwindling supply of
resources here
and if we hope to live beyond our
planet's ability to support the human
race
we'll have to figure out how to migrate
to distant planets
you know it's a huge paradox can we
become an interplanetary species without
destroying the bodies of the men and
women that we send into space
in atlanta there's already a team of
scientists
working to figure that out at spaceworks
dr john bradford has been tasked by nasa
to break through the engineering and
health challenges of sending
astronauts on long-term voyages
we're going to want to send hundreds of
people and those technologies
and the solutions that the aerospace
community has been traditionally looking
at
we're not going to support that so i
started thinking about you know what are
the real challenges
and started to wonder why can't we you
know put humans in a hibernation-like
state
during the mission when animals shift
into hibernation
their body undergoes several changes
that help protect them for months at a
time
slower metabolism cooler body
temperature reduce brain activity
and there's evidence that it's possible
to induce a similar state
in humans
very often we'll see in the news these
kind of miraculous stories
of people recovering from deep
hypothermic states
rescuers work frantically to find two
and a half-year-old michelle
funk the little girl was submerged for
more than an hour
and technically dead but the cold water
chilled her down to 66 degrees
enough to stave off brain damage there's
additional medical benefits
that we see when people are in this low
metabolic state
we think that muscle atrophy and bone
loss will be slowed
we can do things like neuromuscular
electrical stimulation uh to act kind of
exercise their muscle groups and things
so
when we can keep them in a fit shape
during
during the course of the mission you can
also put them in a much smaller habitat
[Music]
but so far simply cooling the body is
only a short-term solution
for long space voyages some experts
think humans will need to enter a
hibernation state
maybe even deep torpor an unprecedented
approach being seriously considered in
scientific circles
there's a community out there that
believes that maybe early humans did
hibernate and that's how they survived
some periods of
uh kind of famines or cold winters so
there's
a group that thinks we could reactivate
that capability
which brings me here to north carolina
where researchers are studying that
capability in one of our closest
genetic relatives here we go
the tail dwarf lemur it's the only
primate in the world
known to hibernate for an extended
period of time
and while we may look different humans
actually possess the same genetic
switches that allow these primates to
hibernate
we just need to figure out how to turn
ours on
what we're doing here at the duke lemur
center is trying to figure out
what the stimuli that induce
hibernation are so it's sort of like
pressing the rest or sleep button on
your computer
to go into low power mode that's a very
good analogy
my guess is that it's built into the
genome
and we humans possess those genes too
but given the modern advances in genetic
surgery
if we could identify the controlling
genes
it is conceivable that we could
induce torpor in humans this genetic
hint
from one of our most ancient cousins
could be the key
it allows scientists to unlock the
secrets of human hibernation
already within us in new york the work
to decode our genome and find these
secrets
is now underway
welcome welcome this is the lab so we'll
take take you on upstairs and tell you
about everything for the study
this is uh where we keep all the samples
that come back from either
here uh before they went up to space
this is where you guys
tweak humanity that's right dr chris
mason has spent the last three years
doing work for nasa
studying the effects of space travel on
astronauts like scott kelly
but in here is essentially you know the
cells that are still viably frozen
meaning
we can thaw them in the cells that were
taken from space will still be alive
dr mason invites me into the cave at
cornell
a virtual reality room that allows
scientists to explore images at the
molecular and cellular levels
but what's remarkable here is that when
you look at all these different animals
comparatively from the mice to the
orangutan to the chimpanzee to the given
to the human
we almost look exactly the same that's
right almost all the pieces are already
inside of us we just have to
put it back and turn it back on so this
is this is basically the frontier of our
human story
this is a road map of what you would
need to have torpor exist in other
species
do you think that in my lifetime i'll be
able to induce something like corpora
you might not get a full torpor
or maybe a half torpor probably within
your lifetime
earth is our home and we have a chance
to figure out how to live more
sustainably on it
but as any society develops and thrives
it has to grow
and eventually we will grow beyond this
planet
sending people to mars and beyond
next on explorer could a fringe movement
of conspiracy theorists
pose a hidden threat to our space
agency's future
you think for the longest time you live
here
but what if it wasn't this and later
are we alone i head to one of the most
advanced
deep space observatories in the world to
find out
every night is a new opportunity to
discover something new
welcome back to explorer 2500 years ago
the ancient greeks
concluded that the earth is a sphere a
theory that has been validated by
scientists ever since
you'd think that with the beautiful
photographs that we have of
our round blue planet it would convince
any doubters
but there are still some who insist that
the world is flat
correspondent marianna vanzella
discovers more about this fast-growing
movement
in california that's the famous blue
marble that everybody's seen
but let me tell you something about that
famous shot
it's not a photo at all man it was made
in photoshop because there ain't no
photographs about somebody tell me why
they're all just focused i'm marianna
vanzella and i'm in southern california
to look into a growing movement in
america
people who claim the earth is flat they
call themselves the flat earthers and
we're here to try to understand what's
behind this unconventional view
and how it can affect the rest of us
so what's happening here today why are
you here this matters to me
flat earth shows you that you are not a
mistake and
you were created and so you have meaning
and you matter to the world we're not
monkeys floating through space on a ball
as an accident
it's not testable it's not measurable
it's not provable it's not
real how old are you guys just out of
curiosity 27.
do you think it's a growing movement yes
and we're networking we're getting
stronger people are realizing it's
coming out in the media
you're hearing the the term flat earth
it's becoming more normal people are
more open-minded
to it he's not wrong a recent survey of
americans found that
two percent believe the earth is flat
for the u.s population as a whole
that works out to be over 6.5 million
people
even high profile artists and athletes
are getting on board
vlad so i want to try to find mark
sargent who's one of the leaders of the
flat earth community
nice to see you man we met mark used to
design video games and run
software trainings now he devotes
himself full-time
to promoting the flat earth absolutely
hi
with all the attention that you must be
mark sergeant i am mark sergeant thanks
for meeting us here
it's uh pleasure to be here
so tell me what is this movement all
about this movement
is about changing the world literally
you think for the longest time that you
live
here but what if it wasn't this
what if this was just the illusion
yeah we're gonna open this thing up and
the reality
looked something like this
[Applause]
[Music]
in a nutshell you have the north pole at
the center
the continents splayed out organically
on the sides
antarctica has stretched around the
entire outer edge like an ice wall
the sun and the moon are very very small
and the stars are just
lights in the sky a giant planetarium
which means it was built by somebody
someone bigger than us
someone better than us do you think it
was a god
not my place to say
your belief in the earth being flat
flies in the face of
hundreds of years years of evidence of
scientific evidence that the world is
round not only that
we have satellite imagery
we have photos from space to prove that
the earth is round
what and nobody here believes
any of that anymore oh it's beautiful
mike really is
so you don't believe that people travel
in space oh it's much worse than you
know
okay meaning the only reason nasa was
founded in 1958
was to keep this thing under wraps as
best they could
think of the shock waves if all of a
sudden you're telling a civilization
that this model this isn't it anymore
flat earth
is the last conspiracy anyone ever looks
at
mark and his fellow flat earthers seem
to be pretty convinced that the
earth is flat and that we've all been
lied to for all these years
i'm interested in knowing what kind of
impact this might have
not only for science but for society at
large
so we're heading to meet with an
astrophysicist that we hope can answer
some of these questions
the universe began about 14 billion
years ago in an event that we call
the big bang james bullock is a
professor of physics and astronomy at
the university of california irvine
he specializes in how galaxies form
did you ever think a few years ago that
you'd be having this discussion
for national geographic it's frankly
shocking we've known for 2000 years
based on observations you can make with
your own eyes
that the world is round but they have
all the evidence right in front of them
and they still choose not to believe in
it
you know who knows what motivates people
from the inside to believe these things
but science is important science is
valuable
science saves lives it makes our lives
better and more comfortable
and it enriches us intellectually and to
question what scientists are saying
and suggested they're part of some
massive international global conspiracy
it's really scary are they a threat to
the work that you do as a scientist
if say governments stop funding science
because of some kind of
anti-science anti-intellectual uh
feedback they're getting from the
populace
that's when it really starts getting
dangerous for our civilization
and as the war on science heats up some
americans are fighting back
we're heading to the largest lake in
california to meet the
independent investigations group which
is a group that essentially
debunks paranormal claims and they want
to do a round earth test basically a
test that will prove
that the earth is not flat but that it
is round let's go we're ready to launch
are you ready craig james how are you
okay okay so what's happening here right
now
okay this is the boat-based target of
horizontal stripes
we're gonna launch a small boat out into
the water here
with a striped target come on teddy
and as he gets farther and farther out
he'll start to lose the stripes
one way that aristotle proved two
thousand years ago that the earth is a
sphere
was with a boat's test very similar to
this one
as a boat approaches the horizon it
appears to slowly dip down
into the water before disappearing
completely
that's got everything to do with the
curvature of the earth
if the planet was flat the entire boat
would remain visible
so it'll be a very visual depiction of
the curvature of the earth and what's
really interesting is that
some of the flat earthers including mark
sargent are actually going to be here
for this test they want to see it for
themselves
what do you think is going to happen
here today i appreciate a scientific
group
coming out and trying to do this test
great appreciate the enthusiasm
but cannot work can it work
i'm ready i'm ready bring it up so it's
starting yeah okay so the test is
starting the test it's starting right
now
at first all the stripes are clearly
visible
but sure enough as the boat reaches the
horizon the stripes begin to disappear
one by one it's pretty amazing you can
actually see it pretty clearly with this
camera here
and you see that the red stripe that was
at the bottom has completely disappeared
and it's now getting closer to sort of
the middle uh
green stripe that is so we've lost about
one and a half stripes
right so this can only happen why
because of the curvature of the earth
so here's what we were shooting but mark
sargent and the other flat earthers
have a very different interpretation of
the results
so you don't think that what we're
seeing is actually real you think it's
because of
yeah absolutely heat does anyone here in
flat earth believe it's a globe
it's still flat anyone raise of hands
it's not a pear either
this is a demonstration that doesn't
change anything for you lord no
mark do you really believe this stuff
tell me the truth i'm serious i
absolutely 100 believe we are not on a
globe
we are part of a giant studio set
uh all the world's a stage and you're on
it i still don't understand though like
who's gaining from all this from this
large conspiracy
the highest authority higher than
presidents uh
the super rich people that are behind
the scenes remember the first rule of
powers stay hidden
so this is for me where i think it gets
really dangerous because we're going
back into the dark
ages right you're essentially
perpetuating
ignorance by denying science you know
there's a real life implication in all
of this
science has had its chance and they
aren't putting up a defense
i think that the flat earth could
potentially
usher in a new golden age or it could
usher in an age of chaos
it's easy to dismiss this as just a
silly theory and unimportant
but the problem is that it's a growing
movement in america
more and more young people seem to
believe that the world is flat
and you know it's more than just
distrusting government it's this notion
that
thousands of years of empirical
scientific evidence
is now being dismissed as a mere
conspiracy and
that's where i think it really starts
getting dangerous for all of us
[Music]
when we come back does life exist on
distant planets
i traveled to one of the most
otherworldly places to find out
so this would have been one of the
biggest discoveries in recent years
for sure if not the biggest and
later when a meteorite strikes the earth
is it scientists or deep pocketed
collectors
they get first dips i have heard stories
of meteorites
changing hands for a million dollars
most of us live under light polluted
skies
the best stargazing spots on earth are
often
extremely remote places like the atacama
desert and chile
where scientists have an unparalleled
view
of deep space and are making discoveries
that are changing our understandings of
the universe
our next story is my journey to see
stars up close
as close as you can get
[Music]
rising more than 8 000 feet above sea
level
the atacama is the highest driest desert
on earth
there are places here where it's so dry
that they've never had a drop of rain
the soil has no water or nutrients
but what really makes the atacama desert
so unique is that they have
clear dark skies untouched by light
pollution
one of the reasons they built the
world's most advanced optical telescope
here
if you're a stargazer worth the trip the
paranal observatory
it's as good as it gets
this telescope tell me why is it so
special
the size of the main mirror is very
important because how big are we talking
8.2 meters in diameters so maybe 24
25 feet the larger the telescope the
more light you collect
from the it's moving yeah it's moving
matthias can we walk up so we can see
the mirror
can we go up so here you really get to
see this
exactly this mirror yeah the vlt's
largest mirror collects the light from
distant stars and planets
from there a series of smaller mirrors
reflect that light onto one of several
instruments
that allow astronomers to study the
subject
how thick is this big one 17 centimeters
so we're looking at about seven inches
or something like that
like that it weighs more than 20 tons so
it's a big piece of glass
wow right but having one of the largest
mirrors in the world is useless unless
you can focus it
that's why you need lasers just like
something out of star wars
a powerful laser beam shoots out from
the telescope causing
sodium atoms high in the atmosphere to
glow creating an
artificial star that allows the
scientists to calibrate the vlt
i mean this is state-of-the-art
instrumentation in astronomy so is
this is the right place uh if you want
to do
the work that you do exactly there will
be also very nice new instrument
i love that look the lights are going
down
look
this is part of the excitement of
working here right every night is a new
opportunity to
to discover something something new
[Music]
the half billion dollar facility is the
most productive
ground-based observatory in the world
advancing our knowledge of black holes
and how stars and planets are born
in 2008 the very large telescope
detected the afterglow of a gamma-ray
burst
among the farthest objects ever observed
near the very edge of the known universe
light from this explosion took almost 13
billion years to get here
giving us a window into the universe in
its infancy
we can go to the control room where we
operate remotely
but perhaps the most significant work
done here is the discovery and studying
of exoplanets
planets outside our solar system
okay so here we are at the control room
and each so each one of these are
control centers for
for for the instrument on that specific
telescope
observation time on these powerful
telescopes is precious
and requests come from all over the
world only astronomers with the best
proposals
get to use them
eliar is an astronomer from iran and
i guess this is a great way to be able
to sort of get a sense of what an
exoplanet looks like yes these images
are really quite extraordinary
we've known about exoplanets since 1992
but didn't catch an image of one until
2004
when the team here at paranal made
history
here we actually have a direct image of
an exoplanet
this is the star and this is a
giant planet is a little bit bigger than
jupiter around that star that we could
take its picture directly
it's the first ever image of a planet
outside our solar system
this exoplanet orbits a star located 230
light years from earth
which sounds far unless you're talking
to an astronomer
it's in our neighborhoods in terms of
the size of the
galaxy because our galaxy is about 100
000 light years
since the imaging technology at paranal
is relatively new and not widely
available
these so-called neighborhoods are still
largely unexplored
but recently the astronomers here
happened upon a potentially
earth-shattering discovery so this is
this planetary system discovered around
the star called trappists rapist one
and they found seven rocky planets
around this star and what do we know
about these planets
what we know is that three of them are
for sure in the habitable zone
of the star which means that there is a
possibility that there is liquid water
on their surface
so are you now zeroing in on these
planets and starting to really
understand them more and more
for sure i mean we are really lucky that
from our point of view
all seven of these planets pass in front
of the the host the star
so as it as it passes in front of the
host star we can actually study
study their atmosphere i learned that an
exoplanet passing in front of its star
is a very important time for these
astronomers for one
it slightly dims the light from the star
making it the best time to detect the
planet in the first place
also as light from the star passes
through the planet's atmosphere
astronomers can identify which gases are
present
and by then studying the composition of
all the gases you start to understand
more about what the potential is for
life that sort of absolutely
yes yeah and your personal feeling is
what maybe there is some life there
entrepius if i had to bet i would say
probably not
the reason that i say probably not is
because
this star emits a lot of x-ray radiation
as we know
the x-ray is not quite good for life but
you never know we we have i mean we only
know one example of life
uh that has evolved in the universe so
we are very inexperienced
you have dreams matthias you have
something that
you're searching for you feel like you
want to find
if we find sign of life
in outside the solar system would be
i mean that i think that is one of the
biggest question of of mankind right are
we alone
in the universe and probably the answer
to this will be provided by
astronomy in the coming decades so
it's challenging but it's also super
exciting
the high-powered telescopes here give
astronomers a groundbreaking view of
deep space
but the remote desert landscape on which
they stand provides a truly incredible
look at the stars
with or without a telescope
for me i've just never seen the sky like
this in my entire life
you can see this this brilliant band of
light across the sky that as
you can see just goes all the way across
beautiful and that band is called
that's the milky way that's the milky
way that's our home that's our home
galaxy
so if we can i would i would like to
actually have come a bit closer to home
and actually have a look at jupiter
if you would like to so that's the
brightest star that you can see in the
sky
oh there there's one right there okay
yeah you can see it right there
oh wow you have it yeah that's beautiful
and
you also see four dots very close to
jupiter and those are
jupiter's moons i really appreciate the
tour
it was my pleasure this state of the art
observatory
and the men and women who work here are
on the vanguard
of an amazing explosion of knowledge and
even with all that's been explored we've
only scratched the surface of the
historic discoveries
that await us on distant horizons
when we come back here in morocco when a
meteorite strikes the earth
there's a rush to find the best pieces
just those two pieces they want twenty
thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars for what's in my
hands right now
[Music]
welcome back while space might appear
like an empty vacuum
it is in fact filled with cosmic debris
like
asteroids comets and meteors tens of
thousands of these meteors become fiery
meteorites
breaking through our atmosphere before
crashing down on earth
these extraterrestrial rocks can offer
rich insight into alien worlds
and are often so valuable they're worth
more than gold
up next cara santa maria goes behind the
scenes
of the global meteorite market in north
africa
[Music]
i'm kara santa maria and here in morocco
when a meteorite strikes the earth
there's a rush to find the best pieces
from scientists to private collectors
everyone's interested in the secrets of
the cosmos that these rocks could unlock
many meteorites are unchanged since the
birth of our solar system
and can tell scientists a lot about our
place in the universe
[Music]
more than 40 tons of interplanetary
rocks and dust fall through our
atmosphere
every day most are lost to oceans
or dense terrain but if the precious few
meteorites that have been found
nearly one in five landed here
best place to find meteorite is in the
desert
because sand is a color hair helps us to
see black stone
from far away
[Music]
oh my vision
my big one it was 22 kilo
and we sell it like 12 000.
in the oasis town of airfood morocco a
large percentage of the economy is made
up in meteorites
known as the gate of the sahara people
come from all over the world to trade in
this precious commodity
michael farmer is a meteorite dealer one
of only 20 people in the world with
access to the nearly impenetrable
meteorite market
i worked at target while i was in the
university of arizona and uh
i quit that job traveled to morocco
started buying meteorites and i've never
looked back
do you travel the world in search of
these things yeah i've been to over 80
countries i never stop anytime a new
meteorite falls
i tend to jump on a plane and rush there
michael has a network of meteorite
brokers all around the world
here in morocco his local agent is
muhammad
in anticipation of michael's arrival he
set up
secret meetings with a small group of
top sellers
the one we're about to meet claims that
he has two rare rocks
out of only 200 of its kind that were
ever found
like a boutique what is black beauty
the rarest mars rock on earth
scientifically it's extraordinary it has
a lot of water in it martian water
usually sells for 10 000 us per gram
yep no doubt yeah very
very very rare rock gold
is fifty dollars a gram just those two
pieces they want twenty thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars for what's in my
hand right now
the existence of this global underground
meteorite industry is actually a huge
problem according to another group of
people desperate to get their hands on
these rare rocks
[Music]
paul chotis is the head of near-earth
objects for nasa
and believes meteorites are too
important to be collected by anyone
other than scientists a meteorite
is a stone that is sitting on the ground
a stone from space a rock from space
it's exciting because it formed in space
four billion years ago
so we can learn more about the formation
of the solar system and the composition
of that early material that was where
the building blocks of the planets
[Music]
so to ascertain kind of the age and when
the fall happened and then where there
are other
related meteorites documentation is
certainly needed
when meteorites are recovered and i i
can't speak to what the meteorite
hunters are doing
scientists like paul have good reason to
be suspicious
in an underground marketplace even
well-known meteorite hunters sometimes
struggle to get the information they
need
should we take our shoes here we sit
here
here okay anywhere you want
grab a pillow oh thank you wow
what's this it's going right
yeah that's a nice piece wow
look at that very nice oriented rock
chondrites are pieces of asteroid and
are thought to be one of the earliest
building blocks of our solar system
nearly 90 percent of meteorites found so
far are chondrites
and researchers consider the specific
details of each rock's fall to the earth
vital to the scientific record but this
dealer is being cryptic about where he
found this one
is saw pieces of this a few months ago
it looks like a fall from algeria
it's illegal to export meteorites from
algeria they're seen as priceless
artifacts and property of the state
so you're concerned about these coming
from a place where it's not legal to
sell them
yeah if i had information on on that
exactly i would buy it but
no information no buy
morocco is the global hub of a booming
meteorite market
but these keys to the origins of the
cosmos are also vital to science
and it seems some dealers are willing to
compromise critical scientific data just
to make a profit
[Music]
if i had information on on that exactly
i would buy it
but uh
but that's a problem
so you're concerned about these coming
from a place where it's not legal to
sell them
yeah at the moment with with the
information i have i won't buy it
i would love to buy it but i don't like
what i'm hearing so i'm out
michael may have turned this rock down
but some collectors look the other way
destroying critical data scientists need
to create a complete picture of a
meteorite fall
there often is a strewn field that is to
say
there are a bunch of meteorites that are
related
together you know and and that mapping
out that field is also of great interest
if the local citizens have picked up a
meteorite and moved it
you know hundreds of miles maybe then
then we have no information
where that fell so in general
my preference is that professionals are
involved in
recovering the meteorites
michael farmer argues that despite some
bad actors the vast majority of
meteorite hunters are careful
and coordinate with scientists anytime i
get a new meteorite
we have to share 20 grams or 20 percent
and that's
been a joint agreement with collectors
dealers and
scientists to make sure that science
gets its share
or at least enough to study
but it's not just out of the goodness of
their hearts in a twist of irony
scientific certification is actually the
best way for meteorite traders to get
top dollar for their finds
i have heard stories of meteorites
changing hands for
a million dollars or in excess of it
james hislop sources of the most
extraordinary meteorites on the planet
i'm really looking for the best of the
best
i'd say for every 100 meteorites that
i'm offered
i probably turned down 98's 99 of them
he's currently receiving deliveries from
brokers around the world for one of
christie's meteorite auctions
wow canyon diablo
named after meteor crater in arizona
most as you know most canyon diabolos do
not look like this
no and when you're dropping the same
amount of cash on a piece of rock as you
would a home
like a home you want qualified experts
to make sure you're buying what you
think you are until it's been formally
classified
by the meteoritical society it's just a
rock
so it then has to basically has to be
cut open
analyzed published then it's officially
a meteorite and then we'll
offer it for sale at christie's this
really has the potential to be the most
expensive meteorite we've ever sold at
christie's
uh it should be it's over here it's a
one-of-a-kind i mean they're all
one-of-a-kind objects but this is
extraordinary
this is really extraordinary at the
auction christie's held in february 2018
this scientifically certified canyon
diablo meteorite
sold for a staggering seven thousand
five hundred dollars
[Music]
so in many ways scientists help fuel the
high prices in the meteorite market
but they also get a lot in return
recovering these incredible pieces of
outer space from
far-flung regions is a costly and
time-consuming endeavor
and scientists almost never have to foot
the bill because the meteorite hunters
are chasing a much bigger payday than
any government budget would provide
okay now that's a nice piece
nice moon rock big moon rock i mean i
jump on a plane i go to india i get the
meteorite and i deliver it to scientific
hands in 72 hours
whereas they may have to write up a
budget proposal and wait a year on
somebody to give them some money to go
and try to acquire a sample
we cut that red tape
that's fifteen thousand dollars fourteen
nine yeah
that's a real card after cutting
polishing and obtaining scientific
certification
michael could clear at least forty five
thousand dollars in profit from this one
and a half pound piece of the moon
he's happy i'm happy everybody's happy
[Music]
in this episode we've seen how enduring
human curiosity is
when it comes to understanding how the
universe works many people believe
our long-term survival as a species will
depend on it
that's it for this episode join me next
time
on explorer
[Music]
you